[Música]
como lo adelantábamos con nuestro primer
invitado del día vamos a hablar de
facebook que confirmó ayer que llegó a
un acuerdo con un grupo de editoriales
francesas para así pagarles por los
enlaces a sus noticias que son
compartidas por usuarios en esta red
social la compañía firmó el acuerdo de
licencia con la alianza de la presse de
información general que presenta
representa a más de 300 editoriales
francesas esto con el fin de mejorar la
calidad de la información en línea para
los usuarios de internet y también las
editoriales en facebook sin embargo los
términos financieros no fueron revelados
para ello ya quiero saludar entonces a
nuestro primer invitado el día del es
juan david castro consultor en marketing
digital y search engine optimization en
2018 ganador de effie awards gracias
juan david por estar con nosotros aquí
en directo américa entonces tras meses
de discusiones y tras los polémicos
casos como el de australia por ejemplo
finalmente facebook se dio a las
presiones de la prensa de las empresas
de noticias juan
si le preguntaba que si finalmente y
tras estos polémicos casos finalmente
facebook se dio a la prensa
si definitivamente hoy en día
el estar conectado directamente con las
noticias de la actualidad y todo el tema
de tener la información veraz en función
de los canales y los medios de
comunicación definitivamente facebook
debe aliarse con los que ya tiene esa
autoridad dentro del gremio por así
decirlo ahora juan podemos ver esto en
otros países por ejemplo con australia
tengo entendido que ya pronto también
van a firmar un acuerdo un acuerdo como
éste
así es así es australia es uno de los
siguientes el espacio donde facebook
está empezando a generar estas
iniciativas hoy en día como volviendo
contabas empiezan a trabajar con la
unión europea' inicialmente con francia
y que pues para el año 2022 iba a
empezar a modificar ya generar todo es
un incentivo directamente a los medios
de comunicación que puedan llegar a
generar estos contenidos dentro de la
red social y que ambos se terminen
beneficiando tanto por el contenido
tanto como por la audiencia que ya tiene
dentro está dicha red social juana ahora
le pregunto cómo funciona esto cómo
ganan dinero los medios de comunicación
y facebook digamos cómo funciona la
política de ganar-ganar
ok la política de ganar-ganar ahí serían
muchas veces tal cual como hoy en día
vemos en las redes sociales los anuncios
los medios de comunicación que tienen
sus contenidos sus noticias estas sedes
eran compartidos en un espacio exclusivo
para estos medios de comunicación hoy en
día en eeuu ya existe esto que es lo que
se les conoce como facebook news y a
partir de estos alianza están estos
editores las marcas y adicionalmente los
editores que serían los medios de
comunicación tendrían la posibilidad de
recibir anunciantes verdad y a partir de
esto los clicks que reciben estos
anunciantes se estarían pagando a dichos
editores en este caso los medios de
comunicación de esta manera facebook
consigue parte de esa comisión de la
venta del espacio publicitario y del
lado de los medios de comunicación
recibo un financiamiento para así seguir
sustentando su modelo de negocio eso le
quería preguntar juan entonces las
empresas ganan por clic o por un tiempo
determinado en la página web cosa como
cómo es el proceso de monetización que
realmente era y lo que importa en este
en este conflicto digamos que ya está
por por solventar si ya estabas
orientados en varios países
si así es definitivamente el tema la
humanización se terminó relegando
solamente en temas de clics tiempo de
retención y el tiempo que los usuarios
realmente terminen consumiendo sus
contenidos además pues sabemos que
facebook ha venido trabajando en estos
últimos años todo el tema era ver esa
veracidad de la información y el tema
contra las falsas noticias falsas esto
es súper importante estar aliado pues
con medios de comunicación que realmente
le permitan tener una información rápida
veraz y que él para llegar a informar a
sus usuarios eso lo quiero preguntar
entonces digamos esta alianza y este
facebook news es una medida digamos que
tomó esta empresa estamos hablando ahora
de facebook para combatir las afines
yo diría que si definitivamente cuando
ya entra en el juego lo que serían los
editores los medios de comunicación para
entregar esta noticia veraz y evitar
todo el tema de contenido que realmente
no sea validado por su sistema de
contenidos por así llamarlo esto pues va
a ser que muchas personas realmente se
terminen solamente remitiendo a una
sección específica dentro de la
plataforma como ya no podíamos hablar
hace un rato lo de facebook news en
donde hay si van a estar obviamente
todas las sesiones de noticias y los
contenidos de esos editores de sus
medios de comunicación que estarán
compartiendo su contenido de manera
veraz aquí el guión de seguramente los
medios de comunicación van a tener una
labor muchísimo más relevante dentro de
las redes sociales y así van a tener un
montón de audiencia adicional a la que
ya tienen acostumbrados en sus espacios
tradicionales de consumo
juana ahora vamos a entrar en su materia
el search engine optimization cómo se
optimiza esta búsqueda en en las redes
sociales juan
normalmente existen múltiples opciones
de optimización desde la parte de los
títulos de la parte de los contenidos e
inclusive la manera como lo terminamos
contando muy bien sabemos que la manera
como las personas hoy terminan
consumiendo los contenidos es una un
gran factor de optimización y si yo por
ejemplo quiero transmitir un mensaje
tanto como de un medio de comunicación o
de una noticia a partir de esa
estructura de ese formato y yo pudiera
hacer una optimización para aparecer en
los primeros ubicaciones y a partir de
eso generar esa conexión con mi
comunidad
le doy un ejemplo si hacemos una
optimización en función de los títulos y
del contenido de la manera como estamos
transmitiendo dentro de esta red social
esto nos va a permitir estar en una
mejor posición ver si nuestros
competidores de esa manera en cómo
funciona un poco el sistema optimización
dentro de los motores de búsqueda y por
supuesto dentro de las redes sociales
que solucionan muy similar osea digamos
que todo esto se reduce al marketing
digital digamos que también los medios
de cancelación tienen que apuntar le
tienen que apuntarle a esto como como yo
como los medios de comunicación pueden
apuntar este marketing digital para que
prefieran una noticia que otra
dependiendo del medio no fue así es así
es definitivamente el marketing digital
vemos que a la raíz de la pandemia tomo
una fuerza importante no solamente para
los medios de comunicación sino para
pequeñas medianas empresas que de una u
otra manera ahora tienen sus apuestas en
estos espacios como las redes sociales y
que hoy facebook empieza a tomar más
partidos y más relevancia para cada uno
de estos usuarios él sabe lo que te
entre pandemia se incrementaron más del
30 40 por ciento de los usuarios activos
dentro de dichas redes sociales porque
fue la único espacio de comunicación y
de iu de espacio de conversación para
muchas personas esto es súper relevante
y es algo que seguramente de aquí a un
par de años seguiremos hablando al
respecto con respecto al marketing
digital